hi I'm Phil Warren I'm a research
engineer who works in the field of
imagery both capture and display and
when I'm not in the lab I do the exact
same thing but with my own cameras and
I'd like to share with you a novel new
exploration I've been working on
imagine a rainbow actually you don't
need to imagine it I'll show you now
this is a pretty good representation of
the electromagnetic spectrum that is
visible light light has a wavelength and
like everything else on the
electromagnetic spectrum we can perceive
everything ranging from violet around
380 nanometers to deep red around 720
nanometers
now as we look up at a rainbow photons
rain down upon us like so many droplets
of splishy-splashy color
however our human eyes can only capture
a certain range of those photons blue
below the blue wavelengths ultraviolet
photons go unperceived but those aren't
what we're going to talk about today and
above the red wavelengths infrared
photons are likewise not seen this means
the rainbow is hiding something there
are unseen stripes too this rainbow and
not only do I need to see them I need
you to see them too that's the problem
we're gonna solve today going back to
the rain of photons our awesome human
eyes perceive color by catching those
photons those droplets of color energy
in cone cells that behave like buckets
most people have exactly three buckets
and only three buckets in which to catch
those photons these buckets which are
actually three kinds of cone cells are
long cones which capture red light
medium cones which capture green light
and short cones which capture blue light
at this point our brain is now given
color information with these triplet
sets of data a paradigm we call the Tri
stimulus model we never directly
perceive the spectrum because we can
never dump out the buckets and sort the
droplets to see what
specific wavelength that photon was
instead we can understand intermediary
shades of color by observing where the
buckets overlap if photons tickle both
are red and green cones we identify
yellow or orange the photons tickle both
are green and blue cones we see cyan or
indigo if we wanted to see the hidden
stripes of the rainbow we'd have to see
the world with cones that perceived in
longer wavelengths say from 760 to 1100
nanometers let's figure out how to do
that cameras unsurprisingly are set up
to mimic human eyes
however the silicon sensor in the back
of the digital camera is by itself and
before the camera is fully put together
actually sensitive to a much wider
spectrum 300 nanometers to almost 1100
nanometers unfortunately if cameras
actually photographed in that range the
photos wouldn't accurately resemble
resemble the world the photographer was
trying to capture see the image on the
left doesn't look right at all
to ensure that cameras do accurately
capture color a manufacturer would now
install a hot mirror to bounce back
photons invisible to the human eye this
is the camera that gets sold on the
market which accurately captures visible
light and nothing else in order to
divine color from this single sensor we
actually coat it with a very fine array
of translucent tiles a color filter
array this only lets certain wavelengths
into each pixel if we think of each tile
as a bucket again we end up with a group
of three buckets again the digital
camera has taken light from the
real-world spectrum and sorted it into a
try stimulus model with a red channel a
blue channel and a green channel now you
can tear apart a camera and rip out the
hot mirror that blocks infrared photons
thus returning your sensor to a state
where it can catch all the photons
visible or otherwise in order to
photograph our unseen rainbow we have to
do this
I wouldn't recommend you do this
yourself there's a shocking number of
screws and that densely packed nightmare
of electronics and moreover there's a
solid chance your camera will never
focus again but there are several shops
that you can go to online that will
convert your camera for you to see in
the full spectrum now if we want a
photograph in infrared we can order
fairly inexpensive filters called IR
pass filters what you're going to block
out all the photons that are visible to
the human eye however if you didn't take
apart and modify your camera all photons
are going to be blocked by this filter
this is all well and good but once we
allow those photons outside the visible
realm onto the color filter array all
bets are off the translucent tiles
simply weren't designed for this so they
don't know what to do they all kind of
fail the same way allowing 50% of all
infrared light in this means our buckets
overlap completely with no different
ation in the infrared spectrum there's
no triplet set of data no try stimulus
model here this has a weird effect when
all the buckets are equally full it
doesn't matter if there's only a little
infrared or a whole lot of infrared the
result is a traditional infrared photo
with pixels that are grayscale
monochromatic this is a white balance
version of a conventional infrared photo
we can't photograph secret beyond the
black rainbow stripes this way we'd only
see a white band of light see I tried
using a camera with the hot mirror
ripped out now there is an infrared
photography community including myself
that leans into this limitation in style
augmenting the monochromatic infrared
with a little visible spectrum and then
swapping channels to create a cotton
candy color which is artistically
beautiful but does not actually offer a
color concept of the invisible spectrum
here's what where we diverge and truly
introduced a novel format maybe we could
reconstruct an infrared rainbow with
three different infrared photographs of
our rainbow shown here in the visible
spectrum except no
filters exist on a consumer market that
create the desired buckets in the
spectrum we can use the consumer filters
I mentioned before that start allowing
light in at different points on the
infrared spectrum but they all have no
upper terminus they all it let in as
high of wavelength as the sensor will
allow meaning they all cut off around
1100 nanometers I use three of these
filters mounting a different one in
front of my lens for each shot to take
these photographs one allows in in
nanometers 762 1102 Pass will call the
result image a 1 allows 850 to 1100 to
pass will call the result image b1
allows 960 to 1100 to pass we'll call
this unsurprisingly image C and maybe
there's a creative way to
computationally derive three separate
buckets I took a look at those three
photos and I took those photos without
moving the camera the light the subject
or changing any of the settings on the
camera was all just the rainbow that I
created using a xenon bulb and a simple
prism now let's not forget that we're
dealing with a digital image here so now
we can crack open the code and let our
true nerd shine I use Python to write my
code for this and remember anytime we're
dealing with the digital image we're
really looking at a multi-dimensional
array of integers what we might call an
M by N by 3 array meaning height and
width of an image and then 3 stacks to
represent the red the green and the blue
channels given that these images are
really monochromatic we can simply
average those channels to reduce noise
and increase sharpness then deal with
each image is a 2d array and by n now as
we have a wider spectrum than we want
but also know the light energy gathered
by the spectrum we don't want we can
actually simply subtract one from the
other to get the spectrum we do want we
can look at this operation as a boolean
on two matrices or a unary cookie-cutter
operation we can do basic subtraction
between images to reveal the light
energy of a specific spectrum if you
only take one fact away from this talk
it turns out you can isolate a spectrum
beyond what optical filtering will allow
by using math to get the lowest stripe
in this infrared rainbow we can subtract
image B from image a leaving us with the
light energy for the Lowe bucket and
then to get the next stripes in the
infrared rainbow we subtract image C
from image B and then we get this mid
band bucket and we already have the high
band bucket an image C so suddenly
possibly for the first time ever we have
a try stimulus model entirely and
infrared because there's optical filters
that weren't perfect and had a little
roll-off there's even going to be enough
overlap to have intermediary shades if
we just drop these into a tiff image
file like a red green and blue channel
we've imaged an infra red rainbow
compared to the visible spectrum rainbow
this rainbow is further out with
narrower bands now because this is a
novel nameless method I'm proposing it
be named after the three Cup game symbol
rig and using the same technique on a
crackerjack loving taxidermied raccoon
we see as domino mask disappear and this
cuddly trash panda is less to hide a
pineapple growing in an arboretum
becomes a ghostly and beautiful thing
and a rainforest orchid loses all of its
attractors for pollinating insects um
thanks if you want to hear more about
this I'd love to answer questions and
chat about image technology I'm Phil
Warren grab me after the talk or visit
my website at Phil Warren photography
comm or find me on social media thanks
for listening
[Applause]
[Music]